good evening members coming make a start
mr. Council hook queen thank you thank
you
okay we'll start by reading the
emergency evacuation announcement in the
event of a fire or other emergency
please exit the building in an orderly
manner
Treena orderly manner to assemble to the
assembly point which is located in the
market carpark please do not delay your
evacuation to collect any belongings
please do not return to the building
until given permission to do so by
council staff please note that this
meeting will be audio recorded thank
goodness can I also ask members to turn
their mobile phones off or switched into
silent please thank you very much
apologies for absence we have received
apologies from councillor Dre counselor
mrs. Shaw and counselor Stanley
substitute members cancer Griffin for
counselor mrs. Shaw any other apologies
received non-members attending
counselor mrs. hoi and counselor sparing
item number 4 and agenda minutes of the
meeting held on the 5th of December just
prior to asking whether members agreed
for those to be signed and you would
have had a statement passed around you
which hopefully about a chance to read
just for the sake of for clarity and for
the audio recording Paul is just going
to read that out for members right this
is the statement from the section 151
officer in response to the query raised
at review committee on Tuesday the 5th
of December under item 7 the treasury
management 2017-18 mid-year review
regarding the security of into
authoritative agreed to check if there
were any specific central government
guarantees in place for into Authority
lending
having consulted our treasury management
advisors blink asset services whilst
there is no specific guarantee from
central government to underwrite local
authority lending in the Local
Government Act 2003 no local authority
has become insolvent today and it is
unlikely that central government would
allow an individual local authority to
default against its creditors
it is therefore judged that lending to
another UK local authority is unlikely
to be riskier than investing in a bank
or Building Society that falls under a
similar national sovereign credit rating
the 2017-18 RDC treasury management
strategy agreed by review committee
prior to full council in February 2017
sets out the criteria for the
counterparties the council will lend to
this states that the council will only
invest with institutions within
countries that have a sovereign credit
rating of IEA plus or above with the
exception granted by full Council of the
UK which has an AAA rating and in
financial instruments which fall under a
number of defined headings which include
term deposits coal deposits and bonds
with other UK local authorities the risk
is further mitigated by the limits on
lending to other local authorities set
out in the 2017-18 strategy which states
that a maximum of 3 million may be lent
for a maximum duration of one year under
the criteria of the current strategy the
council could therefore choose to invest
with other local UK other UK local
authorities although today it has not
done so officers will continue not to
lend to other local authorities for the
remainder of this financial year pending
agreement at the 2018 19 strategy which
will be presented at review committee in
February 2018 it should be noted that
were RDC to remove other
authorities from there agreed
counterparty list this would further
limit the pool of counterparties
available for the council to invest in I
would not allow it to benefit from
potentially higher investment returns
our members happy with that response
from section one five one officer or has
anybody got any questions regarding that
that will form part the minutes so I'll
members happy for me to sign the minutes
of the meeting held on the 5th of
December with the statement that's just
been read okay thank you very much any
declarations of interest including
whipping declarations at all
councillor mr. Mason
okay thank you very much
counselor mrs. Mason thank you very much
counselor Newport thank you very much no
further interest okay so moving on to
agenda item number six which is social
media and the council's communication
process attending this evening's meeting
on for this particular item we have Sean
Scranton managing director and Vanessa
Conroy the corporate communications and
public relations office something this
item came from a request for the public
to suggest possible topics for the
committee to consider a response was
received from mr. James TIPNIS regarding
social media and members then widen this
to include the council's communication
process we were under the impression
that count
mr. James TIPNIS would be attending this
evenings meeting but unfortunately
doesn't appear as though he will be
members will have had a report sent to
them via email and in addition to the
report is an appendix and Paul has also
sent around some additional information
regarding the communication strategy and
the communications protocols there's
quite a lot to read and take in but I
trust that members a better chance to
have a look through that if I may
could I please just refer this to all
the report to mr. Sean Scranton and
perhaps you could just although members
have had a chance to meet if you could
just perhaps go through the main bits
and then answer any questions that any
members have afterwards be appreciated
yes certainly chairman I think what I
sought to do in the report was to first
of all set out the key areas of social
media the council has been using over
over recent times and there was a set in
in paragraph 2.3 so I think I think we
tended to use the the standard social
media platforms that most of us are
familiar with so Facebook sending out
tweets who the council and so on and so
forth so those are set out in in
paragraph two point three and then what
I sought to do on the next page was to
give a short summary of how I think we
see the evolution of the council's use
of of social media so I think that we
perceive that we've actually been
modestly successful when we compare
ourselves to and nearby authorities in
terms of our use of of social media so I
think that's fairly positive and I think
Vanessa can can add to this if you have
particular questions I think we we get a
fairly positive response from from
residents on issues that are raised
through our social media channels
the one thing that I think it was worth
dwelling on for a moment was a platform
that the council has adopted in in the
last year or so called tell me more it's
actually a platform that in its native
form is called gov delivery but what
that platform has allowed the council to
do is to sign up residents to receive
information directly from the council
and that's proved proving to be I think
a fairly successful way of providing
information to residents with links to
relevant information and webpages and I
think that including the
the residents who have signed up for
information directly related to planning
policy matters I think we probably got
in excess of 10,000 residents now
receiving information through the tell
me more a platform so I mean I think
that's pretty pretty pretty positive and
you know it's another way of enabling us
to communicate directly and positively
with with residents and provide them
with information and it's particularly
useful I think for for situations at the
moment there's the consultation on the
issues and options with the local plan
and I think it's a particularly useful
way of being able to share that that
sort of information as that as that
consultation progresses and to keep
people up to speed with with with the
process in the appendix to the report I
sought to answer the the various
questions that you receive from from
from from the resident I don't think
probably it's probably for meeting to go
through those but but you know we have
to answer answer questions chairman okay
thank you very much
councillor mr. Mason it's good news we
don't have to worry about Watford so
tell me more okay that's that was a
heading
I suppose my first question is 10,000
well that's really impressive are they
all really residents and then what I
don't know is if people are no longer
interested is there an unsubscribe box
anywhere on there I don't know that but
Jim those those are kind of questions
that occur to me about our flagship
platform but mister tip most sees is now
a parish councillor I understand he's a
hawk or parish council so yes
I'm honorbound
as a hawk or member to you know to
support him would support him as arisen
to anyway I think it's a shame he's not
here because I wanted to ask him was he
happy with the response that the
council's now given given that he was
suggesting we could do better I'm just
wondering if something untoward has come
up has come along that's prevented him
from attending and that he has an
interest rather than just being
satisfied with that response and I guess
two things one I think we should contact
him and ask him I think it would be
awfully polite to do so we're not
inquiring why he didn't attend we're
asking him whether or not he was
completely happy with the response and I
would like to ask him does he think that
there are any opportunities where we
could do better because although he's
put he's giving us a challenge we've now
responded I don't know and I don't think
we should leave a stone unturned when
there's an opportunity so that's where I
am with it I'd like to hear more from
mr. tip Messiah the other thing I wonder
if mr. TIPNIS could meet with Vanessa
because I think that might be you know
an appropriate invitation to take all of
those things I've just talked about
forward with him if that's what he'd
like to do no obligation okay thank you
counselor mr. Mason I think vanessa was
not in there that she would be happy to
meet them so I think it it probably
would be appropriate to just make
contact with him and give him the
opportunity to to meet if he wishes to
do so um would Shawn or Vanessa would
you like to come back on anything that
can surmise mr. Mason has said at the
moment I mean you know as far as as far
as
I'm aware and tell me more is is a
platform that exists on the on the
website so I'm sure that members who
visited the home page and the website
will have spotted that tell me more
overlay flying up on on the on the the
home page and in fact and think of other
pages and it offers the opportunity for
for residents to subscribe you know to
that information platform I guess if you
if you're not resident in the district
and you go to the right shoe council
website you can probably sign up for it
but you know I suppose I suppose in
reality the people that are likely to
use our website are probably more likely
to be residents than not certainly we've
been advertising the tell me more
platform through various business forums
and business breakfasts and we've got a
particular particularly good sign up
from their businesses in the district
which i think is quite positive a lot of
interest in there in terms of how the
platform works it's it's it's it's
fairly responsive in that you can sign
up for the information that you want to
receive you could sign up for everything
or you could sign up for specific
notifications dealing with particular
subjects and you can log into your
account and you can unsubscribe as well
so it's flexible in that sense and I'm
just just add yeah we've happy to have a
dialogue with mister tip miss and see
whether or not he's got some some
information that we can that we can use
to develop our systems you can yep
every message but see is there
announcers because otherwise it's very
nice okay yeah anchor Zimmerman we can
always we can check that but I don't
know the answer to that to that question
it does it does put me in mind of the of
the emails that seemed to appear in my
email box that that are promoting cures
for tinnitus and and baldness which
which I find rather amusing but I'm told
that actually it's difficult to get rid
of those because if you choose to
unsubscribe it actually generates more
activity but but hopefully that wouldn't
be the case of the writer
well I think I hope I hope no no
Christian oh but we will check that
information we'll check and come back
Thank You counselor mr. hoy Thank You
chairman to follow that as everybody's
always fun a few points first of all I'm
grab my normal rent about the fact there
I think it's quite relevant to this
because I'll come on to that immediately
afterwards we don't even have equality
on time ersity application jetta came
what I report we don't have equality and
diversity implications on a report yet
again we don't and if it disappointing
us it's from the money director I raced
let's start with because I'm sure people
may have well might have seen during the
week a news item around Twitter where
it's very effective for blind people
there is a an element on Twitter where
you you can add a photograph description
to it as well which will be read out to
the user as well as the tweet
so that's why I'm raising the equality
and diversity because that obviously
helps include people who are blind for
instance and I think the Social Policy
media using this way can be very
beneficial it adds another it adds it
lets people who are blind see what's
going on in the council potentially and
with the the picture description before
considering we have mentioned here we
use a lot of pictures moving on from I'd
like to an answer on that as well if we
are aware of that and if we do use that
picture description moving off of that
again I'm I use social media I am under
the impression we use it in a what I
might call an old-fashioned way
we were using social media to report
what we would normally send out on paper
anyway in the way of press releases and
I'm wondering if that's necessary the
right way to use it or the only way to
use it and nothing is where you'll be
interesting to invite the resident to
actually meet to see if he had other
ideas of how we should be using it
rather in the way they are I
as I see it we are using it to issue
press releases an RC Freitas leo so I
see some issues around planning
sometimes come up which is available but
we don't don't see anything else
anything which may interest people or
not I'm interested that we've we've
actually said that young people are more
likely to use snapchat and Instagram but
then we're saying we'll actually will
use gifts on Facebook on Twitter to
encourage them but I think I really
doubt if a young person is going to
follow and join Twitter just to see a
gif
really that was all I was going to say
I'm I'm not sure we we are using it the
right right way or if we at all thank
you thank you um Vanessa so did you want
to come back it was the first question I
think you went to sorry and with regards
to using Facebook and Twitter and the
younger audience we actually do have our
Instagram as well which we are currently
trying to promote a little bit more with
regards to the youth again and the
planning and policy team the issues and
options we're using Facebook to boost
posts now we're going to pay I think
it's about 14 pounds and they guarantee
you 10,000 extra views but you can
demographically target it and we are
looking to target a younger audience for
that we've tailored the questions as
well so that they should hopefully be
more appealing to a younger audience and
that's just one of the steps that we
we're trying to pursue with them trying
to make contact with those those types
of age groups
okay thank you we currently use it on
the website we use a platform at the
moment called HootSuite where we
schedule our tweets and our Facebook
posts I'm unaware that you can put a
description on that via our HootSuite
but I can double check it but as far as
our website is concerned every time the
comms team issue a press release or
anything with a photo we do put a
description down so that people that may
have hearing difficulties will be able
to see what the picture is what's in the
picture yes okay if I mean I think yep
probably we want to give a comment about
the variety of information that we do we
do reach out through social media so I
mean I think it's much more than what
was was suggested I mean I think it
covers everything from you know fun days
Hockley words to the to the weekly
planning list of applications received
to you know so it's a it's a broad range
of information that we actually put out
from prop from the council to try and
engage with residents you've got a
different different number of interests
and certainly they tell me more platform
has got various buttons that allow you
to select the subjects you're interested
in as I said earlier and incidentally it
does have an unsubscribe button at the
bottom as well okay thank you um just
before I was take another question just
this isn't trying to catch her out
Vanessa um can you just tell me when was
the last Instagram post
I'm sure with huge however I do and I
happen to know okay thank you
councillor Newport thank you
it seemed to be sort of driven by
numbers with this social media and tell
me more when in the report it says an
average engagement rate of seventy nine
percent and is that an open rate on
those emails could you clarify what you
mean with engagement rate the other that
with tell me more is to me it's email
marketing so it's all very well having
ten thousand subscribers what happens if
there's only twenty percent being opened
do we then send a follow-up email saying
oh you haven't opened an email for that
we've sent to you for four weeks are you
still interested I think we should be
doing that sort of process because we
could eventually grow a 50,000 pound of
fifty thousand email list which is
basically reaching five thousand people
because that's how many's interest is in
what we're sending out so I think that's
one element to tell me more
the other thing is would tell me more
every time you go on Oxford site it
prompts you
that's bad practice it should only
prompt you after so if you close it and
then visit again we should be setting
that so may be prompt every three days
or every four days or every five days
there should be a gap it shouldn't be
every single time you go on that site
it's a nag screen it's really annoying
and it puts people off that's just
industry standard the report on Twitter
I found to be really basic because I'd
really want to see engagement on there
and demographics so what what are we
reaching we reach in 18 to 24 year olds
and we reach in you know middle aged
people we reach an elderly people on
Twitter
how are you targeting I'd like to have
seen that in the report and is that
something that you can actually provide
do you look at that over are all the
process with processes we use in on
social media will they and do they
conform to gdpr and will they going
forward and that's something that we're
really going to have to look at
especially with tell me more the new
data protection I think it comes in
forcing my it doesn't it yeah in May so
we really haven't got a lot of time to
look at that you know it's not a lot of
time M
I looked at you know Twitter's a really
difficult social media medium to use I
think well I did look at other councils
around our area and Rochford does have
if not the lowest one of the low I you
know I looked at seven different
councils tendering Colchester mold and
Braintree Basil's and Brentwood and they
and you know they're all 9,000 followers
oh it's a numbers game you know are we
we have we got quality followers have we
looked at who's following us you know
it's all very well having huge numbers
people following but is it an effective
tool yeah how are you measuring whether
it's effective so I just like the
answers to those questions please thank
you thank you are you able to address
any of those questions this evening I
think with regards to the data
protection and the GDP are going forward
everything that we do does fall within
that anyway we're very conscious of
photographs that we put out and we make
sure that we have the relevant sign-offs
for for anything that goes out as well
and we don't we don't actually send
anything any information that goes out
comes right back to our website we don't
actually send raw data out
certainly by tell me more
everything will link back obviously
we've press releases we send out
information again but you know we we
look at the data protection side of days
I understand what you do and with
regards to your question about Twitter
and how we monitor it we only use the
very basic HootSuite package it's a free
package and we we could drill into it
and get more information but with the
current package that we have we cannot
we cannot get any further information on
that we're looking at we've just had a
meeting with a company called muster
points and they work it's basically a
platform like HootSuite but based purely
at the focus is local government and
having a look at the the prices for that
to upgrade on HootSuite we would be
talking about 7,000 pounds a year
whereas with muster point you're talking
just over two thousand the the sales
person there is going to come back to us
with some figures but it does look
promising and this is certainly some of
the information that we could get out
and we can certainly target our
audiences a lot more once we have that
and the open rate um I believe that is
on tell me more the seventy-nine percent
is an open rate it's certainly more than
we had before but obviously we can't we
can't see if you're gonna actually read
those emails that go through but it's
promising if somebody's obviously
clicked on the link to take them back to
the website to read the information okay
thank you
with regards to muster point when would
you anticipate hearing back from them if
it's if that cost is reasonable as
expected is that something you would be
looking to go forward with
have the control over the budgets but I
mean it's something that we could
implement very quickly and that would
give us the information that counts the
new porters rise tonight it would not
only give us the information
tithing with community planning
emergency planning sorry so that the
on-call offices can use it it's a much
friendlier platform to use and it also
gives us some security so that
individual officers can sign in as
themselves rather than us using one
signing and it gives us a lot more
control about what's going out and
approving what's going on so it would be
great if we could have it okay thank you
very much counselor mrs. Mason
well all officers are going to comply
with with the normal code of conduct and
their contractual obligations
but it's it's it's very it's very good
point and and I actually think that you
know the general principle of the
comment that you make about the quality
of communication that goes out from the
council is this is crucial
you know that is that is extremely
extremely important you know and at the
moment by the control by and large of
information that goes out through social
media is is is with with Vanessa and
comms team but you know the the question
is how far do we rule that out to
involve other other officers in
communicating information about council
activities and that's something that
needs to be it needs to be I think
probably needs to happen but it needs to
happen in a properly managed and
controlled way to ensure that we don't
have issues with the information that's
communicated
Thank You counselor mule just just a
couple issues one is the government
website WWF UK does actually have
instructions and it is built into all of
the Gov UK web communications channels
systems are not only under there is a
facility or should be this I'm all for
this as a community communications
medium I think we've got to keep it
relatively simple there as has been
pointed out have an audit trail and the
other side of this is it does actually
fit in with more than just communication
it fits in with the concept of early
intervention because we get awareness of
issues it fits in maximizing our assets
because it is actually a pretty
economical medium to use okay MB and it
does enable communities because then we
see the other point that's coming across
and get the feel for things and I'd like
to suggest that we look upon this almost
like a gigantic electronic suggestion
box I would would be surprised if the
social demographics of the people are
actually using it don't reflect the
social demographic of Rochford and if we
have mainly retired older people you'll
find that they would tend to be a higher
percentage but we've got an opportunity
here with this communications medium not
to ask about this to look at perhaps
even the more senior school school
children in our schools and an awareness
of local democracy and and so on so they
can actually be encouraged to have a
look at this and search these things
because there is this issue with younger
people not voting not taking local
government seriously and that some
that'd be quite useful now what I would
like to suggest as it's eletronic can we
have some means of filtering and kind of
data basing the main issues that keep
getting raised so when we get thousands
of messages we want to know you know
what they mainly about and are we doing
some
thing about those issues is it something
that we really talked talk about even
the Jamie's point there where he was
talking about Instagram and the more
modern methods and actually making it
really professional and have we got
someone with a communications degree in
the council somebody was actually into
it
somebody's perhaps switched on I'm
happening you know and I'm not saying
you're not it's just that that sort of
thing because this is the modern world
and I'm all for it really and and it
does fit in with with three of your main
priorities early intervention maximizing
their sets and enabling communities it
really does to do that so that's the
point I'm making okay and the
involvement of perhaps younger people in
schools they use Instagram and snapchat
because they think it just vaporised is
after you've read it doesn't hang around
a lot of dads know like Facebook Twitter
which gets politicians into trouble and
or can do we're not careful anyway thank
you thank you very much counselor mr.
hoi
I think councillor Milne sort of vaguely
mention long the errors are going to
raise again and I think just to try and
explain what I was on about its how we
use the social media that we've got a
policy of using it but I don't think we
ever we have something here which says
probably you see it for which is the
perhaps disseminate information but not
to engage with the residents so I'm and
it's interesting what caster my own said
how that when you look at our Facebook
page there's very few if any responses
or posts from residents is that because
we aren't allowing them on there or is
it because they're not posting on there
there's not very many retweets of
Twitter
or of Instagram because it's not really
being used and this is the issue I think
we unless we have that feedback we don't
know what feedback what the inflation is
as cows to me one said it'd be useful to
know what people were talking about to
us and if we don't have that on those
platforms it may be on other ones but on
those platforms it's definitely isn't
there and not and I would yes and I
would like to know I think that would
probably take off it's a time though
because we had presumably wouldn't allow
unvetted which he says it here we
wouldn't anyway unfitted responses being
an act wean of two Facebook pages in the
district care about what should end the
whole [ __ ] page or more where that they
have to be deleted quite often post
because of the language that amongst
anything else so I'm sure this that
might be one of the barriers to using it
in that way that doesn't mean that it's
not a bad way to get information out
there it just means we just have to use
in that way and not to use it for
engagement
I'd like thoughts on that thank you
thank you are you able to come back on
any any aspects of those points opposed
oh well I can I can tell you that the
two main subjects that we have
engagement on our waste collection and
planning we get quite a few benefit
inquiries as well obviously they can be
insensitive nature and we have date
section issues so we will usually
message people directly but when we care
and where we can answer people we we
certainly do try to answer them you know
you're right obvious a time you know
what can take a couple of seconds for
somebody to type out a question you know
we have to go to the department
certainly waste collection and then we
have to relay out to our Depot team who
then have to come back to us so it does
take quite a lot of time to do that but
we certainly do try to engage with
regards to Twitter we it's interesting
you say we don't actually retweet a lot
I think we've been retweeting quite a
bit of information certainly from places
like Public Health and the the NHS
certainly very recently all right sorry
I thought you were saying I'll be
tweeting I mean we have the it depends I
mean you know we we've put out no I mean
it depends what the subject matter is I
mean we put out a press release about
the open day for the Vulcan Southend
Airport and we got loads and loads of
retweets
it was the most activity that we've had
for a long time so it does depend on the
subject matter you know unfortunately
some of the information that goes big
around residents possibly don't want to
share you know your bins are going to be
emptied all there's a delay certainly on
Facebook
with waste collection we get a lot of
people you don't retweet on Facebook but
a lot of people if we put some
information out they'll put somebody's
name in so that it will appear on their
feed so we are getting that engagement
with people but you know I do agree
there's certainly we could use it a lot
more effectively and using packages like
muster point I think would definitely
help that
okay thank you I've one more member
who's indicated to speak just before I
go to them just on six point one of the
report is his annual cost of any
software and the TMM has an annual
charge you be able to confirm what they
just approximate cause I think we
probably counselor mr. Mason Thank You
chairman as I was the first person to
speak I left a few things out and you
know I've trusted that other members
would would see them and bring them up
and they did they have to a point with
regard to social media policies for
employees there are two arms to that
there's one when you're acting as an
employee which I think has the mrs.
Mason spoke about that equally there's
the social media policy for people who
who are employees but are using social
media for private purposes that they
equally have got to you know know what
they can and can't do around the
council's interests I suppose I've had
quite a few residents who commented on
social media about the existence of the
social media policy for members who turn
around and say but I've got one on me as
an employee not only as an employee but
also acting in their private capacity
around the interests of my employer so
there are two arms to that and I hope we
don't miss the two arms because they're
quite important councillor Hoyt picked
up what he said again to me we're using
and I have had some exposure to managing
technologies we're using social media
platforms as push information we're not
trying to generate an interaction and
yet the very nature of social media
is interaction that's what it's supposed
to be about and I think that's probably
what mr. tipnis or counselor tipnis is
actually getting at and I think to a
certain extent it's because we are
pushing information and it stops there
we're not asking the next question we're
not asking for response we're not asking
for interaction we're not asking for
feedback and I think that it's the style
of communication that needs to be
considered or if we're going to attack
the subject two ways we push and we
equally recognize there are questions
that may need to be answered and we pose
it in such a way to get those questions
so we can understand more about what our
residents really think and I think
that's one of the things that counselors
do or certainly try to do on social
media but I think the council should do
it as a body corporate as well in fact
you should do so the the last thing I
wanted to kind of say is that it's it's
an important series of platforms we we
also have an emerging one it was called
street life it's now next door and it
seems to be getting quite quite quite
big the last time I posted something
personally or or on behalf of myself as
a councillor there were 798 people it
reached which is not insignificant and
that was just the people bordering Hawke
well so you know I think there's
something to explore there and I'd
certainly recommend looking at next door
in any emerging platforms as well I'll
stop there chairman and what I'm hoping
is that you'll manage to summarize what
the committee has felt about these
things and where we go here particularly
with with mr. Tippett
yep Thank You counselor Mason Vanessa or
Sean have you got any further anything
further you'd like to add at this moment
or are you happy for excuse me - your
two-way comms that you were just talking
about there we've them we recently we've
had the budget survey running and we
thought we would trial a Twitter poll
with that which we did over Christmas
and we actually had we've doubled our
figures for the response so far with the
budget survey by using Twitter a Twitter
poll you can you set them up they only
last 24 hours but we had over 175
replies compared to what we had been
doing you know in the in the older style
so you know there's this certain ease
growth there to use social media as an
engagement and an interaction tool
because residents did come back to us
and it's something that we'll be
discussing with our consultation officer
about making sure that further surveys
can are written in a way that we can use
them on a social media platform
very interesting
because I've got a copy of that some
survey booklet at home in fact I'm I
picked it up at a public library and I
was I was very interested in seeing how
it was laid out how on earth can you put
all of that information all of those
questions into a Twitter poll because it
went on for several pages how can you do
that in a few and if you didn't include
the whole survey how on earth can you
actually accept another set of responses
which weren't actually in the same form
as the original in other words you've
done two surveys I don't understand I'm
going to ask questions it was one of the
questions and it was an easy one that I
could translate for a Twitter poll and
with what they're going to do with those
figures is down to obviously their
consultation officer but with all these
new initiatives we need to try them to
see how they work and I will see the
budget survey one of the budget survey
questions was around the services that
the council provides so we thought we
would use it as a tester to see what
kind of response that we had back
because obviously if we weren't going to
get any response or the response was
going to be poor we would need to look
at other methods to
engage able to was about the importance
of counsel services and we I had to
split the question out because you'll be
alright it will it wasn't in a format
that was easily relatable for a Twitter
poll so I spit the question out and I
believe there were seven services that
we questioned on so I sent them out as
seven individual Twitter polls to see
what you know to see what kind of
engagement we would get back and we were
obviously we got that engagement and
it's something that I think you know
I've recommended to our consultation
officer as I say that it's going forward
that we use that because we doubled our
figures
[Music]
we got 175 in total so that would have
been spread out across the seven the
figures which have been sent back as
they've come in because obviously you
know however they're going to display
those figures will be down to the the
department that issued that but this was
a trial to see what kind of engagement
we would get okay thank you that's the
first that's obviously the first one of
that top everybody plans to do any more
all well I mean obviously potentially
yes but we've all with everything on
social media we need to see what works
before we do it so you know departments
but we had a good engagement racing okay
Thank You councillor mrs. Mason
but if you do suppose figures in the
survey
Sooey
no chairman it won't you know it was
clearly an experiment a pilot to
actually get some evidence as to how we
can be use and develop social media okay
thank you okay but I think I think there
was one point that just just thinking
about that that was raised that that I
think Carol Newport made about the the
fly outs on the website and I actually
thought that the fly it wasn't supposed
to appear every time you once you once
you dredge astir so we'll ask for that
to be looked at thank you um I think
that the report asked the committee to
note the the contents and consider
whether to make any recommendations to
counsel from the comments this evening
there are a few areas which I think
members would like some more
clarification and more focus on in
particular a policy to protect employees
of the council on the content of social
media and bit more information with
regards to picture descriptions and
audio messaging I think that's what it's
called isn't it canceled ahoy l-looking
so perhaps I think this might be
something that's better that we asked
for this to be reviewed and a further
report come back in perhaps six months
once you have a decision Vanessa on
whether or not the council go ahead with
possible yep bear with me one second
with a further consultation sorry what
was then can you clarify that muster
point
yep now I think it was I think it was
noted beginning of the meeting that we
would be contacted in to ask if
everything was okay there's no sinister
reason why he wasn't able to attend this
evening whether or not he was satisfied
with the answer they had already we got
and inviting him to make contact with
the council should he wish to discuss it
you could yes I suggest that we make
contact with mr. tipis if he if he if
he's you know happy to have a chat with
Vanessa and goes through the information
that we've we've summarized in the
appendix to the report and add to that
if he wishes to then we can we can do a
written written a written brief written
report and circulate that you know after
the meeting rather than necessarily
waiting for for the next meeting of the
I think of the committee if that's if
that's I think that it would be
absolutely fine I think when the report
comes back to the review committee
perhaps in six months time members would
want to see whether or not a policy have
been prepared or written agreed for the
girls to employees we would look table
see it some try and get some further
statistics with regards to the captive
audiences is there something else that
you would like included yep
Vanessa do you think it would be
possible for you to record all the
tweets that RDC received that so that we
can look at the content of what people
are asking in those tweets and there is
a really easy way to do it and if we
need to know let me know
[Music]
okay
okay and if that could be included
perhaps in the next report was well if
you'd like to see that is there any
other specific areas that members would
like to see included in a report that
comes back with in addition to the ones
we've already covered this evening
counselor mr. Mason
okay so a Venice own and Shawn are you
happy for this to come back to the
review committee in perhaps six months
time with an update as to to where we
are having taken into consideration the
members comments this evening I think I
think I think that be reasonable for us
to give us an opportunity to look at the
issues that have been raised by the by
the committee and okay thank you very
much okay Thank You members
moving on to yes sorry Vanessa you're
welcome stay or depart if you would
rather okay thank you very much
okay moving on to item number seven
which is the emergency planning and
business continuity review attending for
this item this evening we have Matt hold
white the assistant director of
commercial services and Jeff Stacy the
emergency planning and business
continuity officer this item was
requested following the fire at
Greenville towers to establish what
preparation for emergency events the
council had in place members will have
had the report circulated to them and in
addition to that there are some
additional documentation appendix 1 2 &
3 if I could possibly ask you just
described to members the main parts of
the report and highlight any areas that
you feel you need highlighting and then
answer any questions that members have
thank you thank you chairman
avy members I think that the report
probably speaks for itself it's pretty
worth saying a few words perhaps just to
sort of set the scene and set the
context emergency planning in business
continuity well by its very nature
becomes high profile after significant
events as you move from managing and
response to recovery birth phase but
it's based in reality what the report
try to tease out is that the mostly
planning should be and is indeed
considered as part of day-to-day service
planning that's why working with Jeff
closely we've sought to take a more
proactive approach to emergency planning
and business continuity to ensure we
fully consider and explore our local
risks and our approach of those risks
coupled with the resources we have to
deliver those plans so to the report
seeks to set out how we carry out
exercises to test our response and then
build on this feedback and indeed the
lessons learnt in into future plans
it's also worth pointing out again as
mentioned in the report but as a small
Authority our resources are limited and
that's reflected in our approach
into how we deal with these emergencies
so we seek to reallocate resources where
necessary whether need the most and
prioritize service delivery and again
it's in the report we also make full use
of mutual aid wherever possible to
ensure we can the prioritized services
make use of that aid
so in summary that the reports set to
how the council has a duty as you'll see
in report to plan prepare and test our
response to emergencies
the report also sets are how we
discharge these duties through parts at
work in which is key and the preparation
and testing of our emergency plans that
an actual Authority is well-placed
so respond in the event of an emergency
hopefully it's a the report speaks for
itself we have Jeff with us this evening
who will take some more technical
questions and more tapping the answer
areas questions and members may have on
the report this evening thank you thank
you very much
no members are indicated asking
questions just yet oh okay counseling
Newport Union Jeff does any part of this
plan rely on the use of email this is
the first question
okay so um with with communication two
members would how would we expect to be
communicated with
[Music]
yes it depends on the circumstances and
time but yes we could phone you direct
yeah it could be a question of sharing
emails yeah we are looking at you know
we've talked already about the the use
of social media for getting information
around yes we'll be using whatever sort
of source it and you know types of
communication are available to us
sorry as as we already know there's
quite a lot of members that don't use
social media and should we be should we
be relying on Oh or should we have prior
knowledge of how this information would
be disseminated to us because we why the
way I look at it is we're probably feet
on the ground and we could have in in
the case of a disaster or something
simple such as travelers you know
arriving in the district you know
residents may knock on our door they may
contact us by phone they may send us a
tweet they may contact us via Facebook
but how are we expected to know where to
look to the council for receiving the
information as to how the council will
be handling the situation because when
we had travelers in my ward I it was on
a weekend and I phoned the out-of-hours
number and they were just totally
clueless they just Oh travelers and
where are you if that was the type of
questions I I was again I didn't know
where I was going to be receiving the
information from I had no as a new
member I have no knowledge the only way
that I could try and find out some
information was by phone in another
member that had been at the council for
a significant longer time so I would
expect us to have a predefined route of
communication if you like you know some
members you know would be expected to
receive it either via email or via phone
and simple as that really so we know
what what to expect
now it's been our practice so far that
we we will try to contact the the
Chairman and all the deputy we will try
and contact direct anybody who we think
is going to be do you know directly
affected by what's happening because
it's it's their war their parish
whatever in more general information and
that tends to come out on the email and
then it tends to go on to the to the
website for more general information but
as I say if there are people whose area
we're particularly affected then we do
try and speak to them direct because
it's it's a usual thing with with
communications that there's a difference
between getting the information out
there and actually engaging with
somebody to to make them aware of
something's happening and making sure
they've got that message and speaking to
them direct so we do make that
distinction and so if it was something
that was affecting you directly then we
would try and speak to you they yeah the
issue with with care line hopefully the
new service will be a lot better than
that if I may just add to that if it
helps I mean in terms of your first
point about use of email and as Jeff
said yet clearly it's a single point of
failure so that would be our initial use
of how would would communicate if emails
to go down or for any other reason I
think yeah we've identified that the
phone calls can be made to group leaders
initially and then disseminate depending
on the type of information we're getting
and the scale of incident but I think's
interesting linking to the early
conversation about social media and use
of it were think there's a broad
discussion there and use of whatsapp
another potential ways of sharing that
information it's certainly something we
can look at and bring that okay thank
you very much counsel quick
[Music]
Thank You chairman I know that you've
been around various parish councils
asking them to update their load their
local emergency planning than that how
LinkedIn is this in with the various
parishes because this is all
interconnected and when we talk about
communication you're gonna have
situations where you're gonna have
parishes trying to exercise their local
plan alongside what should exercising
its its plan so that they you know
they've got to cooperate and coordinate
to make sure that the response is
actually working I'm an example of
communications we've oh no that's at
Wakering obviously one of the areas that
they're they have to consider in
relation to flooding and as to whether
all normal communications might actually
not be available and so they have the
provision of two-way radios now how does
that then linking we've what what the
district might be doing in that in an
instant where you know people are trying
to communicate in that that's that
perform where the normal communications
aren't available
the in terms of the parish plans what
I've been encouraging the parish is to
do the primary thing is is really to let
us have contact numbers giving them our
contact numbers and asking in return for
contact numbers so that we can speak to
people because you're quite right I mean
they're the people who are seeing and
responding to it they're on the scene
and it's very important that we get some
feedback from directly from the the
front line if you like as to what's
happening
we will certainly seek to to get liaison
officers down there as quickly as
possible to also help with that with
that feedback in terms of if traditional
communications start breaking down then
yes we look at sort of other
opportunities available to us working in
particular with the emergency services
and in the radio systems that they have
currently airwave although they're that
they are looking to to sort of change
that so we use their systems and beyond
that it you know it's looking at if it's
a question of having to send somebody
down there and come back with the
information that that's what we'll have
to do I know I know in one exercise that
one of my colleagues did they they
actually got messages back by horseback
but not suggesting that's necessarily a
preferred method but it's if everything
else fails we do have to be inventive
thank you just before I go to another
member I have a couple of questions if
you wouldn't mind in the report it talks
about rest sentences and it says that
rest centers are one of the key ways in
which the council may be asked to
support my residents these are where the
council uses its leisure facilities to
provide emergency accommodation for
those evacuated from their homes ah
watch the District Council all these
rest centers considered enough
what's the dodgy finger the there very
much an initial place for people to go
know that I mean there is no way that
they are suitable long-term
accommodation they are somewhere where
people can go immediately when when an
event occurs we have sort of plans of
procedures to make them as comfortable
as possible including providing bedding
so on so if they do have to stay
overnight we can make them a little bit
more comfortable but but it's not it's
not supposed to be a long-term and what
we will be doing is a lot of the focus
that we have is working with those
people to to get them into better
accommodation whether is they've got the
ability to through their insurance or
insurers to go into hotel accommodation
whether they've got friends and
relatives they can go to if there are
other places that they can stay what we
then concentrate obviously are on the
people who for whatever reason don't
have that opportunity and you know we
can look at how we can rehome there
it's a prison when you talk about
emergency bedding that's something I am
aware that Kensington and Chelsea
Council had great problems getting at
very short notice do we actually have a
supply of emergency bedding somewhere or
how would we yes we have our own supply
I've also been doing some work on behalf
of all the district councils around rest
centres which has ended up in us we all
used to have slightly different
processes of doing this we now all have
the same process and we all have the
same equipment so that if we were to ask
for mutual aid and then they all work
the same way they all work to the same
forms of processes and they'll also keep
the same equipment okay so even if we we
use all the
you know severe mattresses and bedding
that we've got I can then look for
mutual aid from okay thank you oh so it
talks about emergency volunteers I'm not
right in thinking that emergency
volunteers at the moment are just
members of staff yes and how many of it
and the in terms of volunteers we've
done training we're down to fifteen
sixteen now so it's only a small number
the the way that we use your mergency
volunteers is very much if you're like a
sort of first team to respond so they're
the people that I've done some training
where they've got some experience and
that we we can deploy immediately
they've all agreed they will also if at
all possible help out of ours so there
be the people that are deployed first of
all to really find out what's happening
understand the problem report back to to
the leadership team and from there we
can touch on that point touching on what
councillor Newport said would it not be
an ideal have been an idea for
councillors to have been asked whether
or not to undertake their training
bearing in mind our geographical spread
across the district there no in the
district as well as we all do and no now
Ward's as well as we do I mean 15 to 16
in emergency volunteers I get that
there's an emergency response team but
if all those 15 16 people are from one
particular part of the district and we
as members cover the entire dish would
it not made sense or is that part of
this emergency
volunteers training that's going to be
under station 2018 we would certainly
look to engage with with members anyway
and for them to assist in in
yeah whatever way you know we can agree
between us and this is sort of seen as
best the role of the emergency
volunteers are such as is rather more
specific and they will do things like
that I've done training with them in
running and operating a rest centre so
how that works
we would certainly be more than happy
for members to come in and assist with
that but in terms of the tasks that we
have to undertake sort of more
specialist training that we do for that
but yes more general help we could
always do I think it needs to be
extended to members I think members
should be trained or at least giving the
opportunity to undergo the training to
standardize the the rest center approach
throughout the the county so we're just
literally that project finished at the
end of last year so I'm now putting in
place training for the coming year and
there's no reason why I can't include
the training thank you one last question
I've got through an English report it
talks about various kind of scenarios
worst-case scenarios affecting flooding
it mentions Southend Airport have we
actually identified what is the biggest
risk to our district I know it said
there's recently in August this year we
undertook a scenario before in the block
of flats now I'm assuming and I don't
I'm not knocking that I'm assuming that
was in immediate response to Granville
Terrace in reality is that really the
highest risk to us I'm not aware that
we've got any significant blocks of
flats that may catch on five surely are
there are other areas that we should
have perhaps concentrated on yeah the
the work on following brimful towers was
- as we do with any major incident we do
look at what's happened we look at what
we can learn for it from it and what
implications it may have for us in the
discussions we had what was coming more
out of that
were some of the communication issues
rather than the specific risk for four
blocks of flats or anything like that so
it's it's what we can learn even even if
it's not a specific this to us we can
still learn some from what's happening
in terms of the overall risk there are
risk registers there is a national risk
register which is put in place by the
government there's also an Essex this
risk register which we refer to and look
yeah the top risks are things like
pandemic flu so we plan for that
certainly East Coast flooding is
particularly a sort of affect us the
pandemic flu and flooding are certainly
the key ones they're the main well would
it not have been prudent for the council
to perhaps undertaking an exercise with
the cost of flood rather than a fire in
a block of flats if we don't really have
you do do it as well you do do that as
well
when was that done should that not form
part of this report I would have thought
as many members represent areas that are
prone to flooding or susceptible to
flooding flooding would have been a more
appropriate if I just come in I mean
just in terms of the exercises we've run
we've run a number I think we've
highlighted that is a excellent have run
we have another other scenarios of
flooding of loss of office accommodation
and other exercises that's one example I
think in it's interesting point in terms
of and it's not an issue with the most
planning where we tend to rehearse and
plan for in something that's just
happened and as you pointed out this
whilst this happen it's why that by that
point we're actually looking at other
issues so it's important that we take
that you know it lessons that Geoff
mentioned around the exercises in terms
of cross all our approach to planning
but yes in terms of other exercises have
been a number of them and flooding yes
clearly one them is horny Jenna okay
thank you
councillor mrs. Mason
so
thank you thank you very much
counselor mr. Hawaii Thank You chairman
just a few points
no equalities equality and diversity on
the report I wonder if I was advised by
mr. Vostok that there was no template
perhaps officers aren't use the new
template which has he included you have
read in the report it's fairly
comprehensive and it going on I hesitate
to use the words Grenfell but one of the
issues coming out of there was the the
perhaps the knowledge meant by the count
so that they themselves may not have
been in a position to help properly and
I wonder have we got any criteria by
which we will make that judgment if
something happens in this district well
we were can readily agree that we need
help immediately from central government
and we have a contact number of very
least to do that with regard to there I
know a lot of the a lot of the actions
of the leadership team rather than the
managing director and actually does
refer to chief executive rather than
managing director in the resulted of
that so decisions are made with the
chief executive and leadership team it
says I really think that needs to come
back to decisions made by the managing
director I think it needs to be one
person making these decisions with
ricotta so that's the first question
what will how will we decide that and
are we aware how that would work that we
wouldn't didn't feel ourselves capable
today we're a very small Council I would
say around
I think 160 employees or something head
might be one or two out there so I think
we would struggle to cope and to
maintain our day to day business as well
if there's anything major moving on from
there the other point I think make heard
a chairman and also casting mrs. Mason
and other counselors in that residents
are also expect councillors to be doing
their bit they've they voted for us they
expect us to be helping to some extent I
would would expect us to be help no no
as an article the point of him happy to
be trained even if I was not elected as
a counselor I would still be happy to
put myself forward to make use of that
training we have no core knowledge I
remember when we had the last serious
prospect of flooding research it didn't
happen police were being sent to whole
bridge from outside the area and they
had although they should have had they
had no knowledge of local vulnerable
people or where the vulnerable Park home
sites were they had no knowledge so I
was directing to them and to them so
this is the noise you're possibly
missing out off with with people
actually in the walls on the ground at
the time try not to get make it worse
obviously out there to help so that's an
important point I think I'd be open for
training I'm sure other casters would as
well and again I would also say that
something we've listed at the front or
the Madera listed likelihoods of what
the problems might be I think flooding
is probably a high risk or the airport
is high risk I'd also obviously mention
the prospect of a nuclear power station
a few miles away might also be a risk in
the case of a possible meltdown or
freeze flooding I don't know that would
be obviously very major
what actual scenarios have we worked
through I know you've just mentioned it
but have we actually worked through in
detail
flooding scenario since a couple hours
and Jeff come into maybe some more
detail the question about I think your
second question counsel regarding
decision making I think we sort of
purposely roat's
the that there's sort of the the policy
to enable it to be to be flexible and
resilient in that not putting all
decision-making on Sean if he were
managing directive on the availab at the
time so we actually purposely made the
decision that it will be a member of
delecia team if Sean was present then I
think that was Sean but we were actually
testing some of these plans picking the
worst possible date pick picking a
Friday mid of August when a lot of
people may be on leave for example so
testing this to its limit what do we do
if people aren't available and have to
make those decisions in our world yes I
have a full leadership team there around
the table but when he seems happen
invariably happen at the worst time but
I do take your point yeah I think it's
particularly important through the chain
of command people known who if we've got
I'm not sorry obviously five assistant
directors at the moment who is in charge
who's making the decision if surely
isn't around or the apartment art of the
new
yes the treaty directories is around who
presumably would be after Sean I don't I
don't know do we know I think it needs
to be quite clear you know I take that
point and you know something made me to
tease out after the report was something
we're trying to build vision into
resilience into it but yeah certainly
from an audit point of view the
supporters you make a need to be clear
and I'll take that point I've just you
have to come back on the point of the I
think it's round drawdown of broader
resources for a major incident I think
you were referring to yeah yeah it's
what we term is sort of escalating the
the whole response I mean certainly if
it if it's something that's beyond what
we can deal with then it goes through to
a sort of countywide sort of system of
response which will be led by what they
call it a strategic coordinating group
so be senior people from the emergency
services local authorities other
agencies that might be involved that
could look at bringing in those those
sort of wider resources and then if
we're escalating it up from there we
start looking at cross-border assistance
and then going up to two central
government assistance so literally from
what may start down in Rockford as
something quite small as it yeah as we
find out the extent of it we can go
right up to central government and talk
to two central government departments
thank you thank you very much um
councillor moon yeah Mike my question is
actually there's already structure in
public service around emergencies I mean
I've had experience with teams that we
send out the tsunami and Sri Lanka you
know that doesn't get much worse than
that but they define whose gold silver
bronze and all of this which is the
directors or whoever the planning the
emergency officer is but to make things
very clear you've got very nice quite
full generic report here
but really the Emergencies seem to come
into categorizations there's like a
category one site one which is just
local you can contain it with the local
employee council employees isn't too big
a problem then this can't agree to more
as serious where you're going to involve
other agencies you may well still have
communications could be a rail crash
that kind of thing or something even
bigger than there but when you move on
to the next one this one I've come to
this question about categorization if
you've got a package around that and
someone's made the decision this is a
category two and you're going to involve
the NHS police and whatever fire service
and we know what the process is that is
defined who to talk to and all of that
because there's business at the outer
hours number and then no one can help is
where we're at the mini and and on a
really big really big disastrous
scenario Norfolk County Council had it
their disastrous flooding and all the
cellnet Network went down and parked the
county and they were using rain net the
amateur radio service because there is a
ray net service they will set up VHF
nets right across the county if you
haven't got phones and email there's all
of that so have we got any thought to
actually providing a categorization of
what the emergencies motion would just
be number one when they they'll just be
local stuff that we can handle and then
we can have defined in that phone
numbers and the communications protocols
so we just have an awareness what is
going on so members of the public asked
us we've got an in there to get an
answer to them
and we can let you guys get on with your
business basically from that point of
view but if it gets bigger than that
then there are Willingham's around some
of us even got reflective jackets
for even first aid training the more
people the mirror here for that but
there is a question about the
categorization and this idea of gold
silver and bronze obviously sean is
Goldie's of managing director and so on
and he nominates who's taking that role
and they are aware of in each sort of
broad category of what the problems are
who to get in touch with and so on it's
like a package for each one okay thank
you very much can you do that yeah in
terms of the categorization that there
is a national categorization as you say
most of the things that would be dealing
with sort of local ones but although we
we would still be dealing with it
locally whatever category it was I mean
it could be part of what they call a
catastrophic which is the sort of top
level one would be something like East
Coast flooding but we'd still be
concentrating very much on our our local
bit although there would be a wider
coordination instead of going on both
within the county and uh nationally so
in terms of engaging with that you your
engagement would still be locally but
there would be this mechanism for
escalating it up to to where wherever so
yeah you've asked the question locally
if we couldn't answer it locally then we
could escalate it up even to two central
government I mean in the past I've I've
worked for the government side of things
as well as locally and part of that
escalation process so yes I have had the
as a sort of government liaison officer
I have had the the actual classic line
of being able to say you know Chief
Constable the Prime Minister's office is
on the line to you so it can literally
work work like that to get that
connection between but but your your
contact would be with what we say
locally a lot for district council would
have sort of a package it tells us the
structure ISM if we needed to find
anything out
yeah well what we've tried to do is not
to make special arrangements just for
emergencies so if you needed to talk to
us we would be setting up something in
the office so you would ring through to
the to the Rockford number as normal and
then they would put you through to our
emergency information cell or whatever
we'd set up to to be dealing with that
out of hours yeah I take all your points
there in terms of what happens there but
what should happen is is once we've set
something up we would let the the care
line system know if there were
alternative numbers to phone or what was
happening and sort of keep them informed
clearly from what you're saying that
hasn't happened in the past but that's
that's something I'm working on with
with a new care line system
[Music]
maybe the introduction of an emergency
line
yeah I agree and is something that we
are looking at as yeah again we were
talking earlier about how we prioritize
the resources that we've got
Communications is is one of the key
things in particularly in an emergency
and we would look to reprioritize and
put additional resources into things
like the so what do they call our team
that answers all the phones customer
services yeah putting additional
operators and things into the customer
service to be able to deal with those
increased inquiries okay thank you much
three more the three members who have
indicated to ask questions I've if I go
to those three members and impact just
I'm conscious of time and the fact we
still got another item to go counselor
mr. Mason Thank You Jared I I think I
better pose this question specifically
to two met Hubbard white because of its
nature there's one risk that it's not
mentioned anywhere in this report and it
was the reason why I at least in
parallel with the offices was concerned
about the Granville situation and the
area that's not actually covered at all
he's political risk there's nothing in
there about political risk and it kind
of links across the what counselor who
was saying about command in a chain of
command now we know and I don't wish to
embarrass anyone we know that when we
had our localized flooding that there
was a political intervention and it
wasn't helpful let's put it that way and
one might say that around the Grenville
situation there was a mix of both there
was unfortunate political interventions
and no intervention
and the political risk is one that I
think is is silent here and it needs to
be managed I think we need a proper
protocol that engages all members in a
political risk control protocol it might
be that it but it bans initially all
political comment any comment from from
any counsellor unless they've been
specifically briefed by the council
disaster recovery team or the leadership
team that's where I think these things
go wrong they also go wrong when there
is something that is like Grenville and
it doesn't appear that the council is
doing enough and then residents others
activists become involved as we've seen
and the political response becomes
imperative and because it becomes
imperative it gets in the way of all the
other things that need to be done by
professionals who are working on the
particular you know dr emergency that's
happened there's a hole here I'd like to
see it filled I think it needs to be
filled agent Lee there needs to be a
protocol which all parties all members
of this council subscribe to and ensure
that we don't actually get involved in
political their political intervention
which is inappropriate but there needs
to equally be a an appropriate protocol
when it says it is appropriate and it
needs to be good and it needs to be
effective so chairman I rest that case
you know quite quite openly and I hope
it can be it can be dealt with in the
next iteration of this report which
one's come back just to come up briefly
in terms of translations points around
around Graham fell and the initial
response certainly yeah it's
there was what was the the lack of the
the respond to the speed response coming
the next day and by then it already
built up the world's media were there
residents were already tweeting and the
council slow to respond so we're looking
at part of some of testing of our plans
working with Vaness you heard from
earlier on how we can look at resilience
in the comms team to look how quickly we
can respond at how we respond because
that is key that you respond very
quickly we have this real clear messages
out early for certain in terms of the
political risk I take cancellations
points and one of the earlier training
training schemes you ran out with
members was more broadly around our
response to to an incident but perhaps
the next stage of that is around them
what happens in terms of the
communications and the political risk
and what that protocol may look like so
saying that some we can consider as some
next part of that training 7 I think it
needs to go further than trainer if it's
going to involve training it's gonna
have to involve members to ensure that
they know what to do and in my opinion
members respond most appropriately to
protocols constitutions that's what
that's what councils work work whereas
it's what most corporates do I think
it's going to be more than training it's
going to be more than you know let's
let's let's hope it's an understood
situation let's let's have something
chairman that is completely completely
codified you know is flexible but
recognizes that issue and seeks to
manage it our might use the term control
that maybe manages a appropriate term
I'd like to see this come back I don't
see it come back with that particular
element properly discharged chairman
thank you chairman yes that's I
appreciate comments yeah some we could
certainly bring back in terms of a
protocol or we could bring back to this
committee thank you very much
councillor Cooper
mr. chairman I just want to go back to
the year the volunteers and I know it's
been talked about quite a lot this
evening but as a counselor I was unaware
of the volunteer scheme
now what untapped resources do we have
among our members does the council know
Weber we've got retired paramedics do we
know if we've got qualified first itis
does the council notice myself I am a
fully fought fully qualified first aider
and I was trained as a combat medic but
so you didn't know that and this is what
you need to find out with the members
because the members know their area
they're aware of all the footpaths etc
etc etc and I think that if the members
would volunteer it would be an asset to
your voluntary service Thank You mr.
chairman
thank you very much I'll take about
something you're very modeling back
council Griffin
Thank You chairman have two separate
questions when we had some flooding
problems a few years ago there was talk
of the counts who acquiring some
four-wheel drive vehicles with snorkel
exhausts does the council possess any of
those vehicles No thank you going back
to the gravel flats fire when the people
were forced to evacuate or were rescued
from the tower obviously their personal
possessions were left behind they were
in need of money and the amount of money
that the counts are offered was pork to
me I think it was 10 pounds per person I
may have even been 10 pounds per family
I'm not quite sure do we have is there
an authorization for the council to
issue money to people in an emergency in
an out of hours out of our situation
got it and no is the short answer to
that one and what we would do is very
much look at the the circumstances at
the time
as I was saying earlier with rest
centers very much the the main activity
within the rest center beyond obviously
making people as comfortable as possible
and reinsure it reassuring them as they
come in is to then look at getting them
into other accommodation and depending
on their needs and circumstances we may
do that in different ways which may
involve you know some funding and
contribution that either we have to find
or social services have to find or
sometimes through the voluntary sector
and otherwise so there's there's no set
answer to that it's very much going to
depend I know in the past there's been a
number of issues even going back to the
the Surat is when the North Wales
flooding occurred where they tried to to
sort of give a contribution and ended up
such an administrative nightmare it yes
it'll completely wiped out any benefit
to the people who received it so I think
we've got to go with sort of exist
existing systems of assessing weathers
need looking at the benefits available
and helping people in that sort of way
rather than trying to sort of make a
contribution to appease people with with
some cash it's in the experiences that
I've looked at it's never worked and it
and it certainly didn't work at
grandfather as well and just for the
recorded records no we do have
four-wheel drive vehicles within the
within the council but there's none
specifically fitted with snorkels or
anything for for waiting
thank you um counsel hook wait you've
indicated ask Chris I think is it you've
said it's gonna be brief
Thank You Jared um yes in relation to
service it about vehicles which is
suitable for dealing with issues of
flooded roads and stuff like that
although it may be might be impractical
for for the council to have adapted
vehicles to meet there there are clubs
and various different groups that will
have vehicles that might be suitable
it's that part of the planning are you
have you got direct contact with any of
these sort of like clubs like Land Rover
clubs or four-wheel drive sort of like
off-road clubs etc yes called Rover
rescue
primarily it's it is a Land Rover base
club but they use other vehicles as well
and that's we the contact for that is
not the local level we go through the
county voluntary sort of sector group so
it brings in people from all over the
county so the answer is yes thank you
okay can we make this the final Creswell
councillor Newport was indicated
actually yeah keep it brief um so this
plan is all about how to counsel plans
for these you know emergencies
perhaps the council could consider a
media campaign on how residents could
plan for emergencies as well and what
I'm talking about is things like do they
know where their documents are who their
insurers are etc because I think that
would really help in those situations
you know get a rest centre they'd know
who they were sure are we would cut back
our work as well
yes we have issued that advice from time
to time and is on the that sort of
advices on the website as well for
people we're working just at the moment
on a countywide pre evacuation advice
document which would be available both
as a document and also to put on
websites and send out through media at
the time and that sort of thing so yes
it is something we're off it did so part
of the work that we're doing around rest
centres and improving how those work and
if people are having to evacuate there
is also in conjunction with that work
going on that is looking at sort of
community response and what they call
spontaneous volunteers so people who say
they will help at the time there are
issues in both those sorts of areas that
we that we need to resolve but that's
being worked on as a sort of county
level and we're waiting to see really
what comes out of that because we want
to try and make sure that we sort of
reflect what each other are doing rather
than being a postcode lottery depending
on which district you're in okay thank
you at the very last question
councillor Cooper yes it was just going
back to the emergency vehicles you're
saying that you've got clubs that will
come in from the districts well in my
particular village or my ward
I know of like four or five emergency
vehicles that can be used straightaway
so this is another thing that you need
to be put into the ward councillors to
find out who can volunteer with these
big Land Rovers etc etc I mean yourself
I've got three of them so
that's only a room and that's not coming
out yet and the last question if I'm
gonna use my own vehicle can I have a
blue light right thank you very much
did you were you indicating you wanted
to come back then all okay members that
the recommendation is to know the
contents of the report which we can I
think it's been identified that this
needs to come back Matt can ask you if
you've got an idea of when you would be
able to do that especially with an
emphasis on I think volunteers kind of a
voluntary roll out to members which I
think most members agree would be a
extremely beneficial thing to do and bit
of guards to political intervention as
councillor mr. Mason has pointed out
being included perhaps as a
Oh Seth takes us into a new municipal
years are obvious I think chairman happy
to be less pride for your relationship
June and also just also the focus on
I think member member communication in
the event of a disaster like just to
clarify that the points that members
wish to cover so I'm clear yep dude I
just ask Jared just to just to clarify
so points extending the the voluntary
service that the voluntary training to
members the political intervention
protocol that counselor mr. Mason
referred to and a focus on communicating
and involving members at the time of a
disaster board members at the time of a
potential disaster
okay with categorization yes sorry so is
that clear
brilliant thank you very much thank you
members I'm moving on to item number
eight which was the petition budget you
are welcome to leave sorry
that's twice that I'm not dazeem I've -
number eight which is the council's
petition process unfortunately John
Bostock is away on holiday and Angela
law is off sick so obviously neither of
those brave are able to attend this
evening and the item is referred to the
committee is the petition organizer has
requested that review committee review
the way his request was handled members
will have had the report sent to them
and obviously will be fully aware of
what petition this is in respect of
unfortunately mr. Lamborn was due to
attend this evening's meeting and give
us an idea of what particular parts of
the process he wasn't happy with and
what he possibly was happy with
unfortunately but at the very very last
minute five to five we received an email
to tell us that he wouldn't be attending
this evening
obviously members have seen the report
and additional documentation I would
also advise that there have been some
email exchanges in particular today with
mr. Lamborn
albeit very late and Michelle and
copying me in as well and at the very
last minute he has raised five points
I'm just checking that is the last email
I've had it possibly it was it's opened
up very very last minute unfortunately
and all in favor agreed okay moving on
to item number nine which is the key
decisions document refer to Paul
beautiful
okay so if you all got a copy
13:17 the brownfield register was
already on there from last month
14:17 you will have seen the report that
was issued on the 5th of January with
its decision jus shortly 1517 was
already on there last month and 1617 was
on there last month there are two new
ones 1717 memorandum of understanding
Essex recreation disturbance avoidance
and mitigation strategy
okay
and then the last one is 1817 the
voluntary sector grant allocations which
is the regular one that appears every
year circulated as well I think members
isn't it counselor
Thank You chair and with the voluntary
sector grant allocation I know that in
previous years when I was involved with
that it normally took place before
Christmas and this is now due to be the
meetings due to be held sometime in
middle of February why is it two months
later than previous years
yep sorry counselor they officer little
no they far as I understand it the
chatty used to be held in December just
before Christmas but they've changed it
because the decision is now more in line
with the budget and they need to make
the decision after the budget has been
decided so it's all part of the budget
process they can't be made up and before
them budget has to be made after it's my
understanding yeah is that okay can't
smoke way how many members got any
further questions on any of those items
nope okay moving on to item 10 which is
the work plan again pause you could go
through that okay
next month we have the treasury
management strategy statement and an
investment strategy to come to a
committee and that will also cover the
inter authority loans etc that the state
members are bound from the section 151
today
counselor mr. myson
what what financial analysis of other
local authorities we will undertake
before lending to because they are not
subject to any rating agency I think we
okay thank you very much
okay that's that's fine I'll feed that
back and obviously for next month Neal
we will also have the petition process
back for that then there aren't any
other changes the project teams still
remain
I did I did identify yeah I did identify
a date for the ICT but so I think or two
days that were possible but I think
that's gone by the by so I'll have to
come back out on that with another
selection of dice
and also with regards to the
Constitution the review of the
Constitution I have contacted Angela on
two occasions since the last meeting for
an update and have proposed dates to
continue with it unfortunately I've had
noticed one summer and she's now off
sick so I will have to wait until she
returns I didn't realize that she'd been
sick since Christmas so yeah and she's
not due back before a couple of weeks I
don't think end of this week so
hopefully Monday counselor mrs. Mason
no agree and obviously I I spoke to her
in contact her and she was intending to
get back to me and confirmed and
clarified which everything was perfectly
acceptable
I then wasn't aware that she was off
sick and chased her up for it obviously
had heard that she is if she's due back
this week I'll take up again I think
your question is a valid one she's I
think I believe so I will expect an
answer from her within the next week
counselor mr. Mason
possibly asked to find out at the time
obviously I thought it was Angela and I
wasn't aware that she was off long-term
okay I think Paul has clarified it would
be Angela Hutchins and as Angela law is
due back at this week right okay
okay thank you okay okay Thank You
members meeting closes at 9:47 thank you